Consider now the results
of this thought experiment.
Our casino enabled us to allocate
our 1,000 tokens to 1,000 tables.
We looked at two extreme cases.
One where we put a small bet
on all 1,000 tables, and
another where we put all
our money on one table.
We saw that the expected return was
the same in both cases, about $20, but
the risk was substantially higher for
the single bet case.
This was true for both type of risk that
we looked at, risk to lose everything,
and risk as standard deviation.
When we consider risk and
reward together,
we come away with three lessons.
One, higher alpha generates
a higher sharpe ratio.
Two, more execution opportunities
provides a higher sharpe ratio.
And three, sharpe ratio grows
as the square root of breadth.